welcome to this video playing the Reaper
man with the US flag
let's check this know there's no name
information and that what is playing on
the SSE for a while and he had other
flags before so not quite clear what but
you should make him out of that the US
flag okay we have a torii attack with
the c5 now played from a black and
surprisingly is going for d5 okay I get
this bishop exchanged it's very often a
problem these in the this Benoni type of
structure so I think it's quite okay to
to have it exchanged let's see
I'd like to get b5 in quickly here I
wonder if I could even play hmm could
even play b5 immediately yeah okay that
sound played in a more conservative
fashion mm-hmm yeah if I prepare b5 with
rock b8 he might play a Phi Phi so that
some let's spend this month
yeah I wonder to see intending a form
maybe is how s he wants to have to trade
the bishop
yeah sensible idea
okay I'll make sure to get it b5 he
cannot take everything because of Ruka
one at the end a Bab rook takes rook
takes Bishop b5 okay one check and madam
winning yes he's going form for this
attack it's so often crude but the
dangerous sea for Quincy five I wonder
if I should should play that you and I'm
not meted here quickly
so I think I can I can do that
oops okay if I go hmm yeah maybe him to
threaten bishop takes a 94 taking on f2
he takes takes I mean take take with the
F pawn I'm not some in instant danger
the f6 Knight is still protecting h7 in
this concrete position I'm even
threatening to take on h6 and take on f2
okay this is not relevant anymore if he
takes now takes on g6 a takes oh and
this I didn't expect at all interesting
yeah what is this idea playing f4 it's
not really working okay I'll try to open
up the B file
I think the main issue this game will be
maybe the time situation I'm down about
a minute but now is some spending some
time as well he doesn't really have a
natural place for his King age six was
really an Iridium surprising as some and
as I'm mom just very safe him on non g8
now okay I can also take and pray Ruby -
not sure if I but his King is
potentially weaker than my like I think
and so I keep the Queen's on
yeah well I thought I just I just can't
shake him yes his his skate position is
just wide open now let's see your up see
ADA maybe rugby to move like that
unfortunately I cannot move the night
made on g7 so I need to do something
else
it is also preventing Queen b6 yeah
probably a good move
it's not so easy now
what should I play rupee two runs until
night safar cannot do that
yeah 27 seconds and he's playing very
forcefully with reform yeah he just
gained some space hi morning Chan his
wide open King position is perfectly
protected by the night yeah Luke evaders
checkmate he will see that I guess or
queen h8 is also nice
oh come on don't make a show out of it
you've seen it already
you know he doesn't see it what this is
frustrating always if there's a simple
winning they don't see it it doesn't
matter I know I'm gonna do some time
anyway
black for effects on time you know this
was check check
what's the mate oh there isn't a mate oh
I was just an idiot but this is a mate
check check mate
this is what I initially saw much easier
yeah well in this position I think I
should just be better but for somebody I
just miss played it terribly why what
happened here okay this is this is good
it's very good even yeah that's a shame
yeah I mean it's position is full of
holds at age h6 is just just a terribly
bad move in so there should be some
punishment and this is the punishment
check check this is practically fast and
no white is toast
I'm just invading with all pieces Kings
somewhere and didn't hear that their own
pawns a week rook is coming just to just
lost this position and this is also
quite logical considering moves like f4
which are just terrible
check okay but the way I played it
wasn't so great and this looks really
nice but Queen d4 is really strong
and now it's very difficult to to make
any headway probably I need to play
Queen b6 anyway I didn't want to take
off the Queen's but this is still
compensation for black
I have 94 to attack this weakness that
it's still a position full of holes
so it's playable even with the without
Queens and this now I can see here I get
a Queen b6 you know you know this is
this is probably not playable anymore
the slightest to bed okay well this is
just the maid into what she didn't see
and d5 it doesn't matter i overstepped
the time anyway he just played far too
loosely I mean h6 is also just
completely mysterious why would you not
open the position I mean I understand
that this gives me some counter play but
it still must be the right move I don't
think that h6 this is any good check the
real problem came with them when I at
this position when he played f4 which
basically loses if I if I don't
recapture automatically but take on c3
this is this in comparison is even worse
the rook is saying everything saying
so I lost opportunity here alright
thanks for watching